[Musique]
ok ça reste toujours aussi
impressionnant la dernière fois que je
suis monté sur scène j'avais 12 ans et
la prof de français avait décidé de me
faire le jouer le rôle d'une courtisane
on oublie j'aurai 35 et je suis la pdg
respecter les entreprises de cyber
sécurité et mon métier c'est protéger
l'identité digitale de mes clients
d'identité ça m'a toujours fasciné dans
toutes ses facettes
mais aujourd'hui la raison pour laquelle
je suis là c'est pour parler de
l'identité du futur ils ont peut-être
digital je sais pas si ça vous des
arrivées mais moi il ya dix ans j'ai
craqué j'ai relancé
j'ai décidé d'acheter un téléphone qui
ne servaient plus vraiment à téléphoner
mais c'était un téléphone intelligent
smartphone alors aujourd'hui je regarde
même plus par la fenêtre savoir le temps
qu'il fait je consulte mon application
simplement je demande à syrie ou à
google a de bien vouloir me donner le
temps de cuisson des pâtes
bref ma vie est devenue simple
confortable joly je ne fais rien sans
mes applications
alors on pourra parler des objets
connectés mais tout ça en fait c'est des
choses qu'on donne de nous c'est notre
identité
si je pose une question et je vous
demande si vous pensez si vous avez
sentiment d'être sur écoutes
ah cool bon ma blague suivante est raté
seba donc je voulais vous parler de
mitterrand des écoutes téléphoniques
mais bon on va passer
oui nous sommes sur écoute et toutes nos
transactions sont sur écoute moi je vais
vous parler de mon pizzaïolo parce que
je suis une fan de pizzas mais le vrai
point c'est que je me suis père un petit
leur interrogé mon pizzaïolo à un
deuxième métier il revend mes données
pourquoi moi pourquoi mes données en
fait si on revient à un tout petit peu
en arrière
quelques millénaires comprendre
connaître les populations savoir qui est
qui a toujours été du ressort du
politique
toute institution tout royauté tout
empire s'est construit sur la
connaissance des populations
ça veut dire la maîtrise la connaissance
et la maîtrise donc la sphère politique
à de toute éternité accepté et voulu que
les données des gens soient enregistrées
soit connue soit écrite est donc
finalement on a des tous accepté ce mode
de communication entre nous et nos
dirigeants le deuxième point c'est que
faut pas trop se leurrer non plus on a
aussi accepté la domestication de nos
corps car ça a été la servitude ça a été
l'esclave âge le salariat le prolétariat
la chirurgie esthétique et régime bref
grandes choses mais le point crucial
c'est qu'on a déjà aussi accepter ça
ensuite de manière un peu plus sérieuse
et sans hypocrisie si on se regarde un
peu en face on a aussi accepté la
marchandisation de nos vies qui sait
combien coûte un rein
combien coûte une vie en fait d'un pays
à un autre d'une situation à une autre
nos vies n'ont pas la même valeur et on
l'a acceptée d'une famine d'une guerre à
autre on a accepté ça alors pourquoi ne
pas aller plus loin
pourquoi ne pas accepter la
marchandisation la domestication de nos
identités numériques
en fait c'est déjà fait pourquoi parce
qu'en fait on a créer nous mêmes le
business de lego je sais pas si vous
avez vu mais y'a même pas dix ans on
achetait encore des écrans de télévision
géants
est ce qu'on voulait voir des stars de
cinéma en 3d
et maintenant la guerre commerciale
entre les marques de téléphone c'est sur
la qualité de l'appareil photo le cmfi
c'est ça qui compte c'est cette ce
business de lego tout simplement on nous
avait promis dans les années 2000
qu'internet c'était la liberté on allait
pouvoir se cultiver on allait pouvoir
voyager on allait pouvoir rencontrer des
gens c'est mais est aujourd'hui en fait
c'est devenu une prison c'est pas l'un
panoptique un panoptique en fait c'est
une prison qui a été inventé par un
anglais au xviiie siècle
il ya même plus besoin de surveillants
parce qu'en fait c'est un cercle et
laisse les prisonniers se surveillent
eux-mêmes puisqu'ils se voient tous et
nous on reproduit la même chose sur les
réseaux sociaux finalement en ce juge
on se regarde est en fait c'est devenu
une prison alors bien sûr ça a été
inventé par un anglais alors ça a
forcément été critiqué par un français
est évidemment s'appelle foucault dans
surveiller et punir est en fête
s'appelle le contrôle social
on n'a même plus besoin de policiers
pour se surveiller pour nous dire si
c'est bien ou pas bien cool ou pas cool
en fait on se surveille nous mêmes et ça
c'est un business très juteux
le troisième point c'est qu'une fois
qu'on est rentré dans ce business
on pourrait se demander pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne passerait pas le cap de vendre
nos identités
en fait c'est déjà fait c'est une
question d'argent de flouze de maille de
grisbi l'argent quoi
en fait c'est un business très juteux
chaque jour toutes nos informations
toutes nos actions sont transformés en
date à en donner
et en fait le point crucial c'est de se
dire que c'est pas que les américains
les grandes entreprises américaines
cocorico les français nous aussi en
semaine et donc aujourd'hui il ya
énormément d'entreprises qui se consacre
uniquement à une seule chose c'est
charles intermédiaire entre vous vos
besoins et comment elles vont monnayer
vos données il ya deux milliards des
milliards de données chaque année
sont déversés par ce qu'on appelle le
cyberespace
c'est plus que dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité on en produit chaque jour
chaque jour et encore plus alors
pourquoi c'est pas juste pour collecter
c'est pas juste pour s'amuser c'est pour
les croisés est en fait le danger
il n'est pas dans la collecte des
données il est dans ce que je vais en
faire on pourrait se demander pourquoi
je vous ai parlé de mon pizzaïolo après
tout on se fout de savoir si j'aime la 4
fromages
pourquoi j'en ai mangé vendredi le
vendredi d'avant et le vendredi d'avant
non le point c'est qu'en fait en
comprenant que tous les vendredis soirs
je prends une pizza quatre fromages
en fait ça va permettre à des marketeurs
ou des algorithmes de décidé de croiser
ces données avec tous mes autres achats
et donc de décider de ce que je fais et
de qui je suis il ya trois plaies en
fait à d'égypte mais du numérique
aujourd'hui la première c'est qu'en fait
on devient la cible de marketer on ne
s'en rend même pas compte c'est
marketeurs ces publicités personnalisées
qu'on aime recevoir parce qu'on dit
qu'on est chère au coeur de nos marques
c'est pas du tout le cas en fait vous
connaissez certainement la phrase c'est
gratuit c'est que c'est vous le produit
bon donc ça veut dire que vos données
ont de la valeur
elles ont non parce qu'on va essayer de
vous vendre des choses mais en fait
quand vous allez acheter quelque chose
vous allez vous vendre vous c'est pas
seulement un nom un prénom une date de
naissance avec les objets connectés on
connaît votre régime on connaît votre
taux d'activité on connaît plein de
choses et en fait du coup cette
connaissance nous rendre tous parce que
je fais partie vulnérable vulnérables
deuxième point qui mois commence à
hystériser un peu c'est que non
seulement ces entreprises profitent de
nos données mais elles ne sont même pas
capables de les protéger
le nombre de scandales qu'il ya avec les
fuites
alors tant que ça ne tombe pas dessus on
est tous très très très très content
la problématique c'est que maintenant
avec cette vulnérabilité ses suites
on commence à avoir une vision floue
entre l'identité la vie privée et
l'intimité
si c'est une marque de chaussures ok
mais donner suite
et si c'est un site de rencontres c'est
mon intimité c'est ma vie privée
et là ça commence à devenir à peu près
urgent de se poser la question est ce
que vous connaissez la valeur de votre
identité
est ce que vous connaissez la valeur de
vos données est ce que vous savez le
nombre de transactions qui lie à chaque
semaine à partir de vos comptes
c'est un business comme je le disais et
c'est très très très juteux alors là
trois pièges évidemment c'est pas si
facile sinon on aurait déjà changé les
pièges c'est le ludique ludique c'est
l'amusement
on nous vend des applications pour
occuper notre temps de cerveau tout
simplement et donc à partir du moment où
c'est une application et qu'en plus elle
est gratuite
je transfère mes données en fait je leur
donne accès à mes données d'identité
le deuxième piège c'est l'addiction
figurez vous que des gens qui sont
vraiment vraiment payé pour aller
choisir les couleurs la façon dont
l'application a été créée pour que vous
deveniez addict pour aller acheter plus
vite pour aller commercer plus vite pour
rester le plus longtemps possible pour
recevoir de la publicité
le troisième siège masse et la
complexité juridique
je sais pas pour vous mais vous savez ce
que c'est que les cgu conditions
générales d'utilisation 22 pages écrit
en tout petit qui ne gâche ce moment ce
plaisir on est là en train d'essayer
d'acheter et de lire de vouloir faire
quelque chose il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de ses 22 pages pour essayer de
comprendre qu'à un moment donné on
accepte quelque chose de l'ordre du tu
ne saura pas où vont partir des données
mais tu acceptes tu te sens sinon il ya
l'autre piège cette espèce de
téléchargement qui ne vient pas qui est
lent qui est long juste parce qu'il ya
un cookie ce qui se met entre moi et mon
application
bref tout est fait pour que à aucun
moment on ne puisse consentir
sereinement à ce choix
alors en fait si on reprend cette
histoire de pizzas non pizzaïolo a vendu
mes données
ok très bien certes mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer derrière ils vont les
croisées avec d'autres choses mais il ya
un marketeurs de génie un algorithme fou
qui va décider
qu'en fait ce choix alimentaires parce
que j'aime ça aussi va devenir une façon
de déterminer mais choix futurs
s'appelle l'analyse comportementale
je n'ai même pas encore commandé pour la
seconde fois de la semaine ma pizza que
déjà on est en train de pronostiquer que
je vais en acheter une semaine suivante
ils décident quasiment pour moi est en
fait tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'il ya plus de lien entre
notre identité et l'identité numérique
et le marketing et la publicité
mais c'est à nous de choisir de choisir
nos identités et de ce qu'on veut en
faire or la bonne nouvelle c'est que des
solutions
la deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est que je
me présente à aucune élection j'ai aucun
intérêt à vous mentir
1 soyons pas naïfs cyber espace cyber ça
veut juste dire complexe ça veut pas
dire science fiction les assurances vont
pas forcément nous aider elles ont aucun
intérêt
on peut encore les attendre un petit
bout de temps mais c'est pas eux qui
vont nous prémunir de ces risques
deuxième option il s'appelle tristan
nitot
c'est un grand monsieur d'internet j'ai
acheté son livre le conseil s'appelle
surveillance et il l'a écrit bien neuf
mois mais en fait ils essayent de nous
donner les moyens de protéger nos
identités
ça veut dire changer de navigateur ça
veut dire faire attention quand on a
l'impression qu'un site n'est pas un
site extrêmement fiable de faire
attention quand on crée un compte aux
informations qu'on donne elles sont
précieuses
en fait très très précieuse puisqu'elle
sont valorisés valorisables
troisième solution c'est de faire
confiance aux hackers et non les hackers
les pirates ne sont pas des sociopathes
enfermé dans une pièce avec un champ bon
j'ai un chat ok je ne suis pas
sociopathe et je travaille dans la super
mais l'important c'est qu'en fait ce
sont des gens qui ne sont pas forcément
du mauvais côté de la barrière
c'est peut être notre seule solution
notre futur en fait leur donner le la
dans la société les valoriser dans leur
liberté
c'est nous garantir qu'on saura se
défendre c'est les nouveaux ou gendarmes
petit clin d'oeil c'est les nouveaux
gendarmes
cette société la quatrième solution
c'est la blocs shane je sais pas si vous
en avez entendu parler
c'est une technologie allait à peu près
assez complexe
ne pas le faire ici parce que je suis
pas sûr non plus d'avoir tout compris
mais en fait la blocs shane c'est ça
permet de compartimenter ça veut dire
que grâce à ça je vais pouvoir choisir
d'être qui je veux dans chaque
transaction l'anonymat en fait
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un luxe est
vrai que ça devienne une liberté et dont
je pourrais compartimentée mon identité
dans chaque transaction et ne donnait à
voir aux gens que ce que j'ai envie
qu'ils voient qu'ils arrêtent de croiser
les données pour déterminer qui je suis
alors que je n'ai pas décidé la 5ème
solution c'est la meilleure bon là c'est
la page publicitaire 1 s'appelle crm
d'epitech s le rnd petek comme ça se
prononce et c'est mon entreprise et donc
voilà enfin si vous voulez des selphy ou
des réductions pour protéger votre
identité on peut se voir besoin d'un
petit peu après
soyez nombreux très nombreux mais plus
sérieusement
et pour revenir à cette histoire de
pizzas parce que commence à avoir un peu
faim on n'a plus que deux scénarios
possibles
le premier s'est on se prend pour des
bruce willis à chaque fois qu'on clique
sur un téléphone il ya un fil bleu un
fil rouge et un compte à rebours il ya
quelque chose
enfin on joue sa vie à chaque fois
chaque fois chaque fois à chaque fois on
joue sa vie combien cliquer sur un
bouton
l'autre solution elle est un peu moins
sympathique mais c'est de se dire que il
ya un principe de précaution
principe de précaution c'est qu'on ne
connaît jamais le futur l'avenir
aujourd'hui c'est du business
alors ça touche peut-être pas grand
monde désire bâtir un mes données vont
partir et voilà tant pis on pense
toujours que ça va tomber sur quelqu'un
d'autre en fait la problématique c'est
que rien n'empêche aujourd'hui ces
entreprises de transmettre ces données
ou de vendre à des partis politiques
et on l'a déjà vécu on lan vécu pour des
conditions religieuse sexuelle
toutes nos orientations ont déjà été
fichés ça commence à l'échographie et sa
fille s'appelle les discriminations est
en fête avec ses analyses
comportementales
avec toute cette donnée qu'on connaît de
nous on va pouvoir affiner ces
discriminations et un jour pourquoi pas
dans un monde complètement ubuesque et
peut-être pas si loin que ça décidé que
les amateurs de quel fromage sont des
pervers parfois de fou et hors du coup
comment aujourd'hui me prémunir
comment dire que l'avenir sera léger à
partir du moment où toutes ces
connaissances ne sont pas dans notre
maîtrise on a le choix
on a le droit d'en faire une liberté on
peut pas revenir dans le passé mais on
peut préparer le futur
et donc nous donner nos données
d'identité elles sont vraiment
extrêmement importante et donc si je
voulais que vous reteniez quelque chose
c'est juste que ça a de la valeur ne les
laissez pas partir
elle vous appartiennent elles sont à
vous
vous pouvez décider soit de les
marchands d eau de soin de dire qu'elles
sont au dessus de la valeur mais elles
sont à vous il n'est pas trop tard c'est
pas un discours de la peur au contraire
c'est de dire que cet anonymat on peut
le retrouver et nous préserver j'ai pas
dit d'arrêter les celle ci au contraire
continuer soyons fous mais prenons juste
en compte que cette liberté
elle va se jouer dans les années à venir
et c'est primordial de prendre soin de
vous de prendre soin de vos données est
vraiment de faire en sorte que voilà
cette identité
ces identités de nos facettes ne soit
pas dévolue au monde du business ou de
la politique
je voulais en profiter pour parce que je
parlais du discours de la peur en
anglais ça se dit trac et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe maintenant
donc voilà je voudrais vous remercier en
tant que public puisque vous avez évité
mon second trauma et voilà je suis
heureuse d'avoir pu partager ça avec
vous merci
[Applaudissements]